[Music]
security is one of the key concerns for
all those who would want to come onto
the cloud it could be an enterprise it
could be a start-up it could be a small
business and they all worry about that
data how secure is the data so let's
spend some time talking about security
on AWS security at AWS is job 0 that is
what AWS talks about that is everybody's
responsibility and it starts right from
the infrastructure we spoke about
regions we spoke about availability
zones so availability zones are the
physical data centers and they are
designed to be fault tolerant they are
designed to be highly available so they
are always in a group of two or more so
that way if one goes down for any reason
we will still have the services running
from the second data center AWS has
something called a shared security
responsibility model where they say that
whatever happens to the underlying
infrastructure they are responsible for
securing that infrastructure such as the
region's the availability zones the edge
location they are responsible for that
underlying infrastructure the customers
are responsible for everything that they
put on top of that infrastructure so the
data the application the access the
firewall rules the customer is
responsible for configuring access to
anybody on that infrastructure
by default AWS provides all the tools
and they do not provide any access to
firewalls that we create any user that
we create or any object that we upload
to the cloud
by default it will be private so we have
to explicitly make it public for any
user we have to give them permission to
do something otherwise they will not be
able to do anything whenever we add any
data then it is addressed we have to
tell them who can access it
AWS gives you a whole set of services to
secure your data to secure your
applications to secure your resources
such as servers in the cloud we will
also talk a little bit about the
compliance that you need for your
application to be PCI DSS compliant or
if your application deals with the
healthcare industry and must be HIPAA
compliant and you need all those
documents that say that your
infrastructure is HIPAA compliant
there's a place to go and it's a shared
service so you go and you request
something and you get it take a look at
all that AWS has to offer when it comes
to security it all starts from the
Identity and Access Management
at the heart of it you would have who is
accessing your system and then what they
are allowed to do in that system so we
are talking about authentication and we
are talking about authorization
so AWS gives you so many options to
create users you can create rules you
can manage the credentials on your own
or you can have something called
identity Federation so you don't have to
create a login for everybody if you
already have their credentials in your
Active Directory or if you want to have
them connect with Facebook ID or gmail
ID or LinkedIn ID or Twitter ID they
should be able to do that this is known
as identity Federation and it allows you
to do just that they also have something
called roles where the credentials are
managed by AWS and they are rotated
internally so you don't have to worry
about managing credentials or storing
them in the servers or passing them to
the EPI request
they also have something called security
tokens which are nothing but temporary
credentials and you can allow somebody
to access your application or system for
a few minutes maybe 60 minutes maybe up
to a few hours and then these tokens
would automatically expire they also
have something called multi-factor
authentication
you can have all your users use this
hardware or software device to
authenticate themselves you can have the
MFA set up on their phones and you'll be
sure that anybody who is logging in
should be in possession of that phone in
order to login
similarly for your application they have
something called AWS WAF that is a Web
Application Firewall and in simply to
protect your application you can
configure it to the best of your choices
and it will simply protect you from any
unwanted traffic that you don't want to
hit your application in similar fashion
they have something called AWS shield
that is the service to mitigate all DDoS
attacks it comes in two versions a
standard version and an advanced version
and the standard version is free of cost
so it will block most known DDoS and
other attacks
and you can configure it to protect your
hardware or your resources from any
known attacks let's say you know you
have a lot of resources in the cloud and
you want to monitor them continuously
against any security threat there's a
service called Amazon inspector where
you simply install an agent and this
agent will keep running will keep
producing reports for you on a monthly
basis so the bill is per agent per month
and it is really very economical where
you compare it with other services which
are either paid or open source and not
managed and there's something called AWS
certificate manager that is a service
that simply manages your SSL and TLS
certificate so you can bring your own
certificate and upload it or you can buy
that certificate from AWS and in both
ways you can simply manage those
certificates in one location
AWS gives you that capacity so you don't
have this hassle of managing those
services
now this is a very interesting AWS
artifact that we spoke about so let's
say you need a compliance certificate
that says that the infrastructure that
you're running on is PCI certified
because you are running an application
that takes credit card information or
does some credit card transactions you
could simply come here and then you can
request the artifact that you want so
you have something like FedRAMP partner
package you have ISO certification and
you can simply request that
certification and you are going to get
that certification over here so these
are the suite of services that AWS has
to offer for security apart from that
there are firewalls at your instance
level at your server level firewalls at
your subnet level there are encryption
services you can ask AWS to do their own
encryption or you can run your own
encryption algorithms there are several
kinds of credentials for accessing
different services and I like to think
about it like this there was once a time
when people would not go on the cloud
because of security
and now people organizations banks
government agencies they're moving
towards cloud because their data their
network is much more secure than what
they could have on their own data center
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here